je pense que ça devrait marcher parce
que j'aime ici j'ai mis les ya les
paroles à quasiment zéro il ya vraiment
absolument pas de faim à la résolution
je l'échangé lumia à 963 un truc du
genre on pleure donc et aussi j'ai
descendu les fps donc là ça devrait bien
marcher
j'espère donc ok qu'est ce qui se passe
aussi à leur place et une rue nos bases
on nourrit lopez a bandé 4,6 des six
donc façon espèce de steijns
ok donc la documenta c'est spécial mais
du foot ouais ouais ça il peut être bon
vous pouvez être attaquée mais outre
qu'il va toucher 70 des cas restaient
calmes et calais ces quartiers où il y
aura d un hawk down g4 l'origine pour
défendre ce fou ou alors juste michel
foulard de truffes
est ce que ça marche mieux comme ça est
ce que c'est quoi
ok ça la revue ok super supérieur faire
j'espère que cette fois ça sera la loi
newell pouvait pour les prendre une
forge gadret aussi ces paramètres puis
trader de soutien
ok donc ouais c'est vrai que là on
attaque le pion le pion de 6 ne savait
pas grand chose parce qu'il aura
peut-être des idées de deux 2 matchs de
couloir fausse idée des petits deals et
sur le plancher de parce que là du
couffo dames fondée si ça marche pas qu
aux dames en est fou prendre d'essai
sera très dangereux à cause de deux
tours 10 8
donc il faut faire des trucs du genre à
l'écart et les cas de le dire mais
surtout feront l'objet de prendre avec
le pion on ne peut pas prendre avec la
dame malheureusement à cause de
d'allemands donc prendre avec le pion je
pense pas que ça nous aide vraiment n'a
pas trop envie de faire soi même mais
bon c'est nécessaire turfoo prendre
d'équité car ce pont rouge de prendre
avec le pion ou alors qu'est ce que les
noirs pour faire à la place monte à des
coûts du genre s'améliora peut-être
qu'elle est française
ah oui oui je suis sur le portable
je sors l'ordi portable
donc ouest option j'aime pas trop mais
bon on peut quand même essayer de le
défendre comme ça mais l'avantagé est
clairement passé du côté normand ya
peut-être aussi faux b 5 précédemment
fait la tour ont eu deux peut-être aussi
truc du genre ça
richaud fuyant mais on peut moins 40
lala salaire de 30 points
ou alors c'est juste off c'est juste moi
qui ai l'habitude de me faire brûler à
la chaque fois ah ouais mais je serais
je sur est tellement plus urgent et en
espèce de truc ça se fait ce truc pour
paul su relever en commun
mais du coup ça a pas l'air de trop
marché donc ok donc que se passe-t-il
donc il y aura peut-être des idées avec
b 5 mai des cinq longs métrages imaginer
fou et de 14 à un peu en ferme y en a
trois montées que sa bonne santé en fait
ouais mais ça a l'air pas mal
cette même à 5,6 pour essayer de fixer
tout ça mais bon faut clairement plutôt
faire baisser je m'en fous
c'est ce qu'elle a choisi donc petrov
aux deux prendre avec le pousse à mal un
an du coup ça évite où les baies 3 et en
maintenant la tour se prépare à venir en
deux
son temps est tellement mauvais aussi el
hadj à part du mythe ou à la pendule
pour la 100e anniversaire
c'est ça va jouer dans sa défaveur sont
tous là elle est déjà en retard au
niveau points elle a juste bien jouer la
première partie il a eu de la chance
tout mais ouais parce que ça va faire ça
a vraiment fait l'info des lieux la
peine déjà andy powell avait déjà perdu
son adversaire donc donc là ça risque d
compliqué pour elle donc comment si on
fait des coûts du genre dam des deux il
y aura trois tours 2 et en plus ceux qui
ont des cartes est toujours attaquer
donc c'est pas facile
donc ouais j'aime être que hp est aussi
savait aussi l'idée d'empêcher des coûts
du genre dans mon objet 5 qui la laci le
pion d'attaqué pas ça pourrait très
embêtant 2005
l'un des truands faudrait peut-être que
la tourelle alors les mêmes bonnes
intentions oui mesdames si on ya tous il
ya tout prend b3 bon bah ouais t'es fou
de sa santé en fait bonne journée
alex
je crois qu'il ya pas trop de délais
d'ailleurs cette fois c'est cool je vois
les commentaires à part un jeu je peux
répondre aux commentaires assez
rapidement et je vois vos réponses très
vite aux alors qu'il n'y a pas de 10
secondes de décalage comme d'hab donc ok
ils n'ont pas le temps de vice avis
avant pas d'offre très secondes mais la
pollution est bien pour elle je pense
que c'est clairement l équipe ou ceux
qui poussent pour lyon donc là l échange
de tours c'est pas super rien parce
qu'il y aura des hommes promet 3 qui
défend les 2 juin donc oui en effet il
vaut mieux garder l'autre où je pense à
moi et qu'il y ait des idées comme ça
fuit ya peut-être des idées sur sur le
roi qui s'est foulé ce cadre que se
passe-t-il fordham des caresses alors
certaines des cartes ya peut-être fois
justice droit prend et tour des 3 ça
c'était un bon peut-être fo prend 2,6 au
nom il faut prendre si l'adage trois
essais marc simon a ouais ouais donc la
dame trois salles à totalement normal
peut-être closier quand même avoir des
idées comme ça wade à me 7,7 bien aussi
mais du coup il va essayer de parler
change d'âme et en même temps être
défense option il faut faire danser
c'est peut-être en échange de dame ça
servait à rien vu que les finales de
football ont poussé centre et un égal au
il faut progresser ça vaut prendre 6 il
n'a pas fait elle a doublé mais ça avait
l'air de gagner
un banal peut le faire
a perdu autant c'est fou ça elle était
super bien l aéroport de transit c'est
la paire de boutons dommage pour elle
donc la baixa lyon revient aux nouveaux
niveaux record faisant 2 partout donc
c'est cool c'est cool pour elle
donc là il ya peut-être une petite
petite pause il reste 35 minutes et 42
secondes
donc là je pense que c'est une pause du
club toi le temps arrêté de couler
on a vu ses deux salles ouvrait lapouze
surtout vu qu'elle ne reprenne pas ouais
ouais c'est dommage pour elle c'est
dommage
mais bon elle a aussi loupé beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses comme ici on veut
avant ici elle pouvait faire bâiller
point fera non pas ici c'est un peu
après quatre médailles qui bien sûr
c'était mon as été ici pour prendre des
civils parce que tu as faux prend b3 il
faut me sentais sagan la donne ici et
pouvait le faire mais là nous payons
encore après on l'a perdu autant mais je
pense que j'aurais pu soudain de france
est donc bon là je pense que l'on est la
moitié déjà on est à la moitié des
dessins plus de donc il ya toujours une
petite pause qu'on arrive à la moitié
des 5 plus de 2 et après on reprendra
enfin pour reprendre ans avec +2 pour la
deuxième moitié après ça sera alors du
budget 3 du 3 avril 2 donc là en ce
moment c'est la petite pause où on
attend que ça reprenne
bon bah du coup franc à 30 ans je me ces
femmes at il pose à temps il y avait il
ya quelqu'un qui vous commencez en
dévalant pourquoi est ce que tu penses
qu'ils sont sexistes les échecs
raconte nous ton opinion way du coup je
t'aime j'ai quand même temps ma petite
pause et je reviens de suite
bon bah du coup je suis est de retour
mais ils sont toujours pas repris donc
du coup je vais répondre à ta question
que je viens de voir donc pas en fait
c'est je pense que c'est juste pour pour
faire jouer pour encourager les
féminines a vu vos échecs
parce que sans ça il y aurait pas trop
de deux filles qui voudraient jouer
parce que enfin après ça un voiturier
des reds va merci merci aux deux raids
alj hakim et à dix coups maïak
merci à vous deux donc de red bank ou
c'est fait c'est fait
c'est drôle ça fra bat pour que ça
arrive donc merci à vous deux et du coup
je vais pas je peux pas trop de faire de
shout out fait ce que je regarde avec
beaucoup mon compte perso mais mais vous
pouvez vous auto aux touches à voter
donc bienvenue aux raiders 1 qui nous
qui nous ont rejoint et on n'a toujours
pas repris
donc là c'est toujours la pause on
attend que la deuxième partie du match
ardu que la deuxième partie des 5 plus
de reprennent
et j'imagine
donc on attend toujours normalement ça
devrait reprendre bientôt mais juste
juste pour le petite info en fait là il
y aura deux parties aujourd'hui
d'habitude ya seulement un match par
jour abadie assayas a repris il ya
seulement ambages par jour d'habitude
mais aujourd'hui exceptionnellement il y
en a deux donc ça va être assez intense
donc là je vais peut-être faire un
scream de six ou sept heures 7 heures de
suite
donc là il ya le premier là le premier
match ici après il y en a un deuxième
match entre deux nouvelles joueuses qui
m'ont qui vont qui vont jouer ça sera
trente minutes après le après la la fin
du premier donc je pense que j'ai même
parlé d'escrimé juste continuer donc
voilà ça a repris et c'est encore une
écossaise
c'est encore une écossaise est là elle a
bien joué elle a bien joué avec le tour
h3 elle a bien fait là pas oubli sa
prévoit cette fois on a fait bien c'est
qu'après twh
donc là sur la je pense que quelques
elle sait ce qu'elle fait
donc oui donc là je pense qu'il est
toujours en prépa mais fou mais sept
tours 1-7 il n'y a pas vraiment de
moyens de continuer là donc là je pense
que c'est même pas très bon de faire
tout prendre c'est parce que rassurant
enfin dans quoique dames c'est ça que
c'est pas top parce que parce qu'il ya
fouet trois donc donc fou b737 que se
passe-t-il c'est ça la question
c'est la question des prix offerts en
fait peut-être je serais ce que dame
baker iii et peut-être dans le b 4 en
fait sur fou en fout des deux ont fait
d'un enfant b2 ou alors cavaillé c3 et
tout est fou c'est cinq peut-être non
mais faut savoir qu'il ya toujours à 4
donc en fait ça marche pas ce mot donc
faut trouver un truc là dessus si ça se
trouve il ya rien en face
si à trop bien s est pas mal pour les
blancs peut-être mais bon cette position
me semble que bon qualité qui a détruit
du genre des cinq ou six mêmes sur d'un
bec a calé ses trois peut-être quatre
des cinq
ok alors peut-être en route et 5 et sur
retour à 5 e simplement bouger le fou
monange dit non parce qu'il ya tout
récemment n'ont pas bougé le faut
surtout un singe que faire sûrement des
six alors ou alors en fait tour à salfo
b6 tout reprend 1,5 peut-être qu'il faut
prendre à eux deux ça serait drôle que
ça marche suroît point f2 cavani g4 est
bon on dirait que ça gagne que ça gagne
1 à tours ça l'a vraiment pas mal ça en
fait je pense que ça gagne si le voit ça
sera vraiment ça sera vraiment super
intéressant donc faux v6 tout prend la
scène vous prend et ce2 / d'un prend
bien sûr il ya dame prend 1,5 et sinon
bah si le roi bouge basse et enfin les
noirs ont simplement gagné aucun
ah non je pense qu'elle a vu qu'elle a
vu qui les aurait elle est revenue et là
les blancs sont quasiment obligé de
prendre sinon le seul autre coup c'est
de faire un tour 1 3 mais ça personne
n'en a envie de le faire donc voyez là
elle a pris d'aller prix donc là c'est
le moment de vérité
espérons qu'elle le voit
bon faut quand même faire gaffe parce
que du coup à la fin il y aura faut
prendre des 8 mai mais je pense que
c'est quand même un petit avantage pour
eux pour les noirs mais surtout il n'y a
pas trop de peau parce que mais à ce
moment là ces ne fait pas ce faux
problème du haut ou la la qu'est-ce que
la paix ok donc à la fin notre sacrifice
à la paf et celui auquel on auquel je
pensais donc toujours 8 qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
richeux 2 ouais ça leur pendait ça va
pas mal c'est à dire à peu près jouable
mais bon je pense que c'est quand même
un avantage pour les blancs là parce que
notre homme sait que s'il arrive à
ouvrir ce fou elle va bloquer l'autre
fou donc faut que la sorte le fou
d'abord après qu'elle pousse et ça
pourra voler de fou mais les pieds noirs
peuvent être activés ça c'est vrai il
faisait noir peuvent éventuellement sous
développement alors c'est les rôles et
les lots chez cependant comme bien sûr
il ya il ya quasiment aucune fille qui
m'ont dit on de 1130 ou alors de 1750
comment ça je pense qu'il y en a il ya
juste louis fernique ya c'était le bla
ya voyage qui naquit est proche mail
elle a même pas encore du lycée sans
joie donc oui bien sûr ça c'est leur
métier et je crois que vaille et xavi et
les éléments fins il doit vendre je veux
pas dire non mais je pense qu'elle doit
avoir de 1350 entre du jour parce qu'
elle n'est pas médecin dans la sono là
encore les justes
elle est juste mettre enfin grand maître
temime donc elle à un niveau beaucoup
moins élevé que leyti n'diaye qui est
quand même une très bonne joueuse leyti
n'diaye les grands maîtres non croyants
il ya une grosse différence de niveau
méambly ça se ressent pas trop parce que
le franc beats on en oublie tout peut
arriver
donc voilà ça me paraît normal pour
essayer de pouvoir bouger le fou après
peut-être aussi faire des trucs du genre
foufou des trois sets de taper sur le
cul en fout des quatre c'est ainsi
normal j'avais bien se trouver en plus
ce genre tournée parler un peu un peu
plus tôt pour des fous des cars pour
essayer de faire ses cinq essais
d'ouvrir des fous sans se faire enfermer
mais la papesse à la fédé 5
donc
[Musique]
voilà donc tous réfutent peut-être c'est
peut-être tantale pourrait faire des
trucs du genre qu avait caressé d'ouvrir
et de faire des impressions sur l'option
fcfp yeux
comment on peut un peu plus tout ça m'a
intéressé 1 pelissier en fait ici je
pense que fout des cats auraient été
vraiment bien peau pour les nord déjà
ou alors ou alors il est aussi faux des
cas suivi de ses seins je pense que ça
aurait été vraiment vraiment bienvenu
mais reprenons donc elle a fait ça donc
x 5 à huy la fois 5
je pense qu'il y aura faut prendre et
psy suivi de d2 s'effronder 5 salaires
marty difficile à défendre donc vous
prendrez les psys cg prendre ces points
des cinq faut prendre ses trois
meilleurs il ya des processus salaires
des gros avantages d'un
ouais ça c'est vrai les deux feux noir
ouais surtout si la coulisse on commence
à s'ouvrir
ils peuvent faire un peu peur mais là il
y en a déjà un qui sait qu'ils
s'échangent et l'autre va disparaître
aussi peut-être pendant voit maintenant
ils vont juste échange et une paire de
fou est bon la vanille charlie se
retrouve avec deux chanteuses
ça fait quand même beaucoup là je sais
absolument pas pour elle réfléchit cette
bizarre de réfléchir qu'elle veut faire
x 1,6 à ouroux g4 ok donc
ah oui elle voulait éviter faut prendre
ouais parce que si elle faisait des
princes et rois tout de suite il y avait
faut prendre g2 et après on apprend et
auprès d'eux alors là il ya peut-être
des fous et froid auquel elle a de plus
en plus dans tous les cas hélas il n'a
pas grand-chose à elle n'a pas peur de
mon choisy tourbillon le salaire de
gagner ses quatre ou à quatre dans l'air
de dating sur ces 6 alors elle a juste
un reprend
ok donc ça leur prix montent à 3,2 en
leur faveur de balle et xavi de ce super
c'est super ça donc ok donc hop c'est je
crois qu'elle a ces jeunes-là échalier
je sais pas exactement quel âge est là
mais je crois qu'il est assez jeune donc
ça serait cool quelques airs et sur la
gagner lighting jumeaux ci est jeune
mais elle est un peu me rejoindre et je
crois qu'elle doit être ni en 97 6 jeudi
pendant die charlie je ne sais pas mais
je pense que je pense qu'elle est assez
jeune bonjour gagner donc voilà ça va
donc ça c'est une défense aux states
comme doivent d'ailleurs et qui doit
être déjà je mets ça rend donc la sueur
sur fou prend ça attaque le curé 5
si on prend et 5 du coup ça sera un
échange aux dames on se retrouvera à
prendre au sens qu'après ou alors on
peut aussi éviter les charges d'un mais
faire dindane le 2 mai mais échange d'un
salaire des biens en fait parce que des
francs 1,5 qu'amélie province un sur
d'un projet en torrents d un coup franc
et kateri de pareilles abord touré 1 à
la fin et vu qu'on a aucun lien messin
et puis s'il est au football il y aura
beaucoup et découverte du genre cavalli
g6 6ème 5 y aura et froid qui chassera
le fou donc ça a l'air en fait d'être
super mauvais pour les noirs ça donc je
pense que prendre 5 c'est pas trop
possible justement à cause de caves et
les provinces enclavées pour les cinq
salles et recoules faut prendre 4 aussi
direct ça serait une erreur et qu'il y
aurait des trucs du genre dame peu d'eux
donc là avec vous là il ya pour prendre
et se prend ce pion a eu 4 n'est pas
imprenable
alors je sais quoi vos pronostics pour
ce match alors vous êtes plutôt pour
l'indian eaux ou la chinoise alors
ok alors cavaillé psy ce donc là c'est
possible de doubler les fonds ouais on a
une très faible peut-être fou effet être
aussi pour attaquer mais avons eu
peut-être défendre ce pion tout
simplement sans se créer de sutil mais
faut il faire sans la part d'un petit
j'aime bien de bien ce coup ou alors
jusqu'à laisser trop weppes wave 4 ok
donc à y prend un cadre c'est ça qu'il
faut calculer si la trouve il ya quelque
chose
quel point caste ou un f4 et f5 f3c 5
watts un énorme salaire des salaires de
gagner qu'à briller sa caisse qui gagne
heures pour faire quelque chose avant il
peut faire grand roque
ah oui le fameux parce que du coup
surtout en katia tour des rangs ok ok ok
donc qu'elle ait pas en quatre en fait
ça marchait midi face à marcher quelles
épreuves quatre tours 1 et il ya grand
surtout pour un kart ya pour dix ans
donc voila mais elle l'a pas fait ne l'a
pas fait bien sûr un plus haut c'est
aussi divisés la voir donc oui donc là
il défend le cumin et des champions et
en même temps ils attaquent le clan c7
oui je suis je suis d'accord que la
linguère a l'air bien parti way et s'est
bien préparé aussi froid elle l'a fait
débat ne sera pas au début votez pour la
gagnante ok ça c'est facile tu seras
toujours tu vas toujours gagner des
paris ses fils est toujours pour la
gagne ans donc là bon là pour elle est
super mal placé
ouais
donc voilà j'ai cassé peut-être possible
en fait pas prier et 6 peut-être faire
des simples un truc comme ça
ou alors je chassais lecavalier après
l'essai de tenir avec jet avec l'as rome
peut-être même prendre ici après prend
1,6
ouais moi je prendrais en 18 tout
simplement mais ça que ça échange les
pièces je sais pas si c'est nécessaire
oh ouais mais bon c'est calme en tueur
basso surtout sur tours vite après il y
aura une cave et penser s'attaque aux
races étaient contrôlés dans qui a pas
de souci de ce niveau là
wendy robie décoller pour quad pourquoi
est ce côté c'est on voit tout quoi ils
ont une chaîne youtube je crois
maintenant d'ailleurs j'ai regardé
quelques unes de leurs vidéos
2 6 1 pour essayer de prendre contre la
casse des quatre têtes elton john a
essuyé du coup il ya quand même temps en
fait parce que moi aussi j'ai joué à
cannes une fois j'ai fait une taupe
johnny se trouve c'est en même temps un
2010 moi je branche pc en 2010 ou en
c'est drôle sader s'y retrouve on l'a
fait en même temps tu jouais en qu'elle
l'a capturé à ce moment-là à moi
peut-être marques telles que c'était en
ouais c'était peut-être un peu avant moi
je crois que c'est un 2009 en fait tous
un roc
moi je vous rappelle plus je devais être
pupilles à ton premier du genre n'ont
peut-être pauvres sinon tu as à faire en
belgique rappelle plus mais c'était cool
c'était une belle équipe quand
tais toi là pour essayer de passer sur
son attaque et des pions peut-être aussi
faire x 3
c'est cap c'est intéressant parce que si
elle prend il y aura tour c8 et les
pions seront assez faibles
donc ça peut être assez intéressant ça
donc je pense que prendront ces cas ça
serait une grosse erreur parce que ça
détruit la structure depuis il vaut
mieux ne rien faire je pense tu as un
truc du jour h4 voilà comment le revoilà
ou alors peut-être prendre mais bon
c'est ça fait pas plaisir de prendre
ouais mais je me rappelle de cette
équipe c'était la belle époque
mais si à ce moment je me rappelle plus
si c'était en 2009 ou 2010 mais du coup
c'est un très bon c'est à ce moment on
est à jamais dans la même équipe
ah oui du coup elle a laissé prendre
et donc là il ya une grosse la blessure
sur b3 dont il ya peut-être aussi qu'il
restait 5 qui arrive
ouais comme elle l'a fait et là sur
france 5 elle aura le choix elle peut
prendre soin en b 300 à 4 face au haka
bon c'est prenable à cause du cloud h /
/ / la tour donc c'est pas évident c'est
pas évident mais ça devrait aller quand
même
je pense que ma moi personnellement je
prendrai en b3 mes lordi préfère de
prend 1,4 pas là pour le moment elle a
un petit avantage aujourd'hui le redis
il dit qu'elle est un plus en pointe
rang en point 30
la chinoise dont comme eh oui c'est vrai
que et les pins en super forme on dirait
je crois que j'ai joué contre elle en
plus d'imagés live ça me dit quelque
chose sinon je crois que j'ai ma et et
mac complètement exposé quand j'avais et
quand j'avais 12 ans je crois à un
championnat du monde dames âgées des
mauvais souvenir de son nom
mais bon maintenant elle est devenu
grand maître à l'est est vraiment moi il
a vraiment assez forte mais bon moment
taquet pas très fortes ont envie de ça
ce serait qu'elle devrait pas perdre
contre rencontre buju aussi a quand même
200 amendements un par un au classement
comme ça mais en plaçant fidèles à 200
points 2
ouais donc là le cul en l'air mais c'est
vrai que leurs ouailles peut pas elle
il peut vraiment vraiment passé et oui
donc la latte l aller chercher ce pion à
attaquer peut aussi passer de ce tout
autre côté mais montrez là lui qu'elle a
choisi de tata qui celui-là c'est un peu
trop tard changer de plan qui 6,5
peut-être ouais ouais bah c'est carcela
c'est un bon coup en plus c'est que
fossiles et plus on est là car si on
n'est pas né pas ne peut pas y accéder à
cause du cavalier je pense que c'est
peut-être même davantage marc mais il
nous reste que 12 secondes ça pas vous
c'est vraiment pas c'est je pense pour
gagner
ouais donc là je pense que ça va quand
même suffisant mais même en est la somme
en rappelant que ouais non en fait ça va
c'est pas possible c'est pas gagné quoi
qu'il arrive ça ne sera jamais gagnant
deux points noirs ça s'est passé juste
part aussi parce qu'elle est la seconde
aventure encore donc là si une personne
cherche à gagner c'est clairement les
bancs tables chef de char gestion et
après j'ai essayé de pousser ses propres
aucun
pierre est à faire ouais non mais même
ça ça marche pas ça marche pas ou alors
ça c'est archi nul archi même ça s'y
retrouvent a attendu 10 pas sa passe et
trouver à réussir c'est l'arrière a fait
retour à vis tu as aimé la juste à sac
et après elle pousser après il va gagner
redouane ue qu une seule et même monter
niveau score ok super donc ces trois
partout maintenant et il reste un peu
moins de 10 minutes et après on passera
aux 3 + 2
bon
donc elle a encore joué là même que un
peu plus tôt cette fois elle n'a pas
donné le q5 et la page de ces quatre
avants y avait quelqu'un elle a perdu
plus de 5
donc cette fois là ont pu mieux jouer
mais bon l'écossais je pense que c'est
une ouverture qui est vraiment très
difficile à jouer si on connaît pas bien
la théorie c'est policiers dément je
pense que c'est vraiment pas bien pour
les blancs c'est wells et d'essayer
c'est super difficile surtout qu'il ya
plein de clins 10 des infos bk détruit
leurs défauts leurs ouailles obligé
d'aller en baisse en dix ans et le
négoce assez sympa où je la jouais en
plus quand j'étais petit
chaque jour je les expose et l'autre
donc j'ai rapidement inchangé
d'ouverture mais bon je pense que ça dit
plus ça fait deux choses à propos de moi
qui fait que la fraude l'ouverture
dimanche du coup j'ai des mauvais
souvenirs de l'hypothèse
mais bon ça c'est si la performance
aussi prouve que c'est pas penser à ces
et lacolle gagné la première partie
d'ailleurs assez rapidement la probante
il avait joué avec avec hk c'est aussi
un poil à gagner était déjà gagnante ont
dit oui mais après il a fait un peu dans
la deuxième partie après ben salah on
verra on verra ce qu'il se passera
bon bien au cou ouais faut bouger ce
cavalier ou est ce qu'on ne bouge de ce
pont de boujan à 5 pour attaquer pour
attaquer ses 6 si on prend b6 ça ça
valait ceux des blue ça valait se
dédoubler elle a fait le bon choix je
pense devenir enceinte peut aussi sortir
son fou en aide quatre fous dessins
poèmes 4 à 8 des cinq feux rouges
ok mon cas ça a l'air bien pour les pour
les blancs ça a l'air pas mal
dès qu'on peut pousser ses carte b4
essaie de faire des trucs comme ça ou
alors c'est juste jouer calmement avec
avec tout essayé de mettre des tours là
je crois qu'il ya pas trop de souci dans
cette position sur deux là les noirs ont
quand même des pions doublé qui sont
assez sains assez à papa très simple la
table qu'on peut faire des bébés 4 / /
faut des 4b caf ou des 4 que faire alors
bah moi j'aimerais bien bougé la tour au
mieux au fond mais y'avait qu'à l'étroit
sur b4 donc as calaf avec ses 4 c'est
mieux je pense c'est mieux parce que du
coup elle peut faire b400 avoir les
soucis avec la casse et 3 comme elle
avait avant voilà donc la fin un bon
chemin là si elle fait b4 donc prendre
ses 7 mai au prince et qu'il y avait
tour prend b2 bon voilà c'est mieux de
fermer quatre après le flou jusqu'à
léopard et un bon si le fugu jambes et 6
on revient je pense avec lecavalier et
sinon si le fou des cas on peut faire
ouais sur flu ouais donc fou des six
petits 6 donc si on prend des doublés
pions mais si on prend balle au fond ce
double nous reprochions donc ça c'est
pas un très bon choix pour nous mais on
n'a vraiment pas envie de te dédoublés
c'est bien on va surtout qui peuvent
être assez fort avec la poussée de 5 des
cinq plus tard mon coeur ouais mais
c'est un mauvais choix en affaires c'est
pas mon choix qu'on aime bien surtout
place ils ont été détruites genre c'est
5 fu pranger 3 après il ya toujours 3
qui arrive donc c'est vraiment dans quoi
je pense qu'on est obligé de prendre
pour ne bougeait prendre malheureusement
pont après après la reprise on va
essayer de décrire des soucis donc bon
j'imagine que sur fourrages et 3f
frantour 3 elle a peut-être prévu de
faire cailler c5 et surtout pangée 3
elle veut elle veut peut-être pendant et
pied
c'est après en deux sets ce qui a l'air
d'être pas mal en fait je pense qu'elle
a fait un très bon choix en faisant se
couche et la réussit à à manoeuvrer son
cavalier hélas le mettre sur les boîtes
à une meilleure place au kebab à yoff
pas loin bon du coup là elle réfléchit
donc elle a choisi de ne pas prendre ce
fou donc j'aime vraiment ça manière
d'ailleurs parce qu'une fois que le
cahier se retrouve en danse et ça sera
ça sera pas mal mais bon là les
quasiment que j'ai de prendre je pense
parce que le cas il est attaqué on n'a
clairement pas envie dernier ce fonction
d'un de ce fou c'est un terrible 1 à le
penser car tu vas tomber satis intérim
donc plutôt faire faut prendre des 6 mai
sur sur ses proches comment faire alors
assez prendre la tête retour d un voyage
une caution pouvait faire tourner un
wayne on leur dit prêteà retour touré
pense qu'elle est ce qu'elle a joués
lors dit damien donc cavelli bouger du
coup là là on pourra vraiment faire la
pression sur ça et si aussitôt ou le
pion en rouge on pourra mettre le client
c'est un petit on peut mettre de faire
des trucs du genre f3 est passé le roi
f2 à ses 5 h m par ce coup je passe
beaucoup parce que en cette can on
voulait utiliser pour le cavalier c'est
à ces appareils grand-chose de de faire
ça surtout plane aurait peut-être pu
faire flouer 6 pour acheter pour
attaquer le cavalier sur cahier des
quatre rouges et le fou alors prononcé
cinq mais bon ce coup là du coup c'est
bien parce que
m caillé en d4 ça c'est cool m leroy l'a
peut-être
de cavalli là
donc là l'idée bien sûr c'est de mettre
le cahier avec 4 ne pouvait faire gaffe
à ça donc appris qu'à y être
4 que faire alors non non donc elle a
choisi de de paris là il menace a évoulé
elle apparaît cette menace fou et ça
mais bon là le fouillis pour revenir en
défense après ça parle pas le choix de
toute façon il pourra pas venir là parce
que il y aura quelques pensées 6
donc peut-être on peut même essayer de
pousser g3s cavaliers après si kabila je
crois bien sûr on fait en faire rager du
kavé sera très mauvais je crois donc ça
peut se tenter
donc là on a bien envie de pousser les
pions
donc j'ai trois c'est normal peut-être
prendre et après essayer de passer le
roi en d4
ou alors voilà prendra peut-être mètres
la tour aussi c'est possible ouais ça
c'est bien vu d'être car c'est un bon
coup après le roi il sera super bien
après c'est pas si facile de gagner ça
mais même en france et craignent un gros
avantage
voilà donc la fauvette tourner progrès
tant pour rien sur as a poussé le fou
doit revenir peut-être en d3 ou alors un
peu d'eux mêmes et on aimerait bien
pousser les pions mais ça sera vraiment
pas possible à cause du plan b 4 avant
qu'on repasse la tour là mais à ce
moment là il y aura il y aura sûrement
des moyens de nom n'empêchait donc
lécher la course est bien si la troupe
vient même à 5
je pense que la même somme et a fait
mais c'est ce qu'elle a fait tomber 5
mai après sur la prise de pousser ses
six le temps s'écoule et donc ça veut
dire ça sera la dernière partie c'est la
dernière partie de 2,3 plus de 2,5
pouces 2 et après ça passera en 3e
donc à la russie est rouillée à ce taux
voilà s'inscrit du jeu avec la colonna
donc si les bravos jura et au roi mais
il y aura tour b3 dont c'est pour ça
qu'il est venu en c2
ouais ça a l'air d'être muette sans
salaire des tenues ça va être difficile
de passer
peut-être courageux pour attaquer le
pion h
bon elle réveille chez beaucoup les deux
toutes les 2 fins mais là surtout ça
elle a passé beaucoup de temps ici
après qu'elle me faire x 6 non ce n'est
pas pour rien que j'ai tant que ça à ses
besoins à auquel elle a fait la fête se
révéla perpète donc tout rage de ce
normal ok donc ça
voilà la différence avec me wade pour la
garde à ces fonds sont aux noms donnés
pendant que ces fonds elle aurait pu
reprendre avec nokia joue alors la tour
mais la vraie claque yonghua auger mal
pour elle la m à cassel samedi à 1 902
redire après ça je crois
elle continue en plus elle c'est à dire
qu'il a vraiment les nefs pour continuer
cette position
bon et bien chinoise va encore gagner
non merci je suis ni mais jamais à ce
niveau là faut pas continuer partie
commence à coincer ce fait c'est
tellement enfantin je pense que de
pontivy tellement dont je sais pas ce qu
elle même ce qu'elle espère avec les
blancs elle elle veut juste faire le
show je crois bondues qu'on attend on
attend qu'elle échange de samuel hockey
enfin là elle a abandonné donc bon assez
fini en fait les 5200 salins de terminer
donc ça sera bah ça va commencer les 3 +
2 bientôt donc l'assainissement de la
peau je pense seulement de la pause et
après ça va ça va reprendre bientôt
du coup tu coupes à moi aussi je vais
faire ma petite pause et je reviendrai
une fois que les parties reprennent donc
vous verrez ça à l'écran donc moi je ne
pars pas je gens l'aiment juste la
jeunesse mc hammer donc comme vous
pourrez quand même par l'écran donc à
tout de suite
ça y est nous avons pris depuis un petit
moment et je suis de retour
donc voilà donc la ctu nourrit le pas
une ride lopez 1 je crois que ça
s'appelle de jeu par ses juges justice
ne sais pas comment ça s'appelle
et voilà donc là les blancs en le centre
qui dans les pionts au centre donc ça a
l'air pas mal ça lui arrive d'être assez
assez paisible à jouer
ouais donc la foux me fous des deux
c'est logique pour développer le fou
mais en 2d pouvoir faire avec ce fou
plate objet parce que le maître en c3
c'est pas top quoi il sera mangé par les
cavaliers et en plus même dans le
meilleur des cas il ya deux jours sur la
structure de pyongyang se fout il est
pas tout si on fait des trucs du genre
dames c'est en ça marche pas trop parce
qu'à chaque fois le roi il va pouvoir
défendre avec avec euros ht est au
secours la japon pas trop parce qu'il ya
gagné ses cinq je pense ça a l'air pas
mal un problème ouais donc c'est ce
qu'elle a fait assez logique
assez logique ça
et h4 aussi donc si le fou repart mais
aux mvno que quoi faire en pâtit le four
à bois donc cahier hkd s'est pas tu sais
pas je sais pas si ça les rats ont fait
menaçant mais aussi d'europe et si les
foudres par ont fait beau mon pote
ouais ou alors bézy c'est pareil et on
peut même tas de faire ces cinq de plomb
et ses avancées en bêtise maintenant sur
ces cinq des prendre ces cinq qui aura
peut-être fou prend 1,5
ok j'ai 5 ok je m'attendais pas à ça
donc bon là la blague fruits ouais donc
pas peut-être dam des trois potes c'est
un petit travaillé fort dans le métro
sous le fou il peut pas trop bouger un
endroit qui peut causer des problèmes
pour les noirs et bon sinon si la dame
rouge en faire le fou il encore ouais si
le faux bouge c'est pas trop ça fait une
super à une super place pour le fou même
en même on peut échanger les dames et
même essayer de pousser cette simple
peut-être y apprendre c'est trop avait
gagné 1,5
donc là le pion celle ci s'est attaqué
mais peut-être qu'on peut le défendre en
faisant des trucs du genre tour 6
peut-être ok donc sato pense ici d'un
problème de nombreux mais de salaire
normales mais l'a pas fait elle avait
peur de quelque chose aux parents
moi j'ai pas de quoi les rêveurs bloqué
l'a pas fait
tu es toujours aussi sexy ou alors
peut-être même dame 2005
bien sûr d'un médecin qui a peut-être
fou pranger simple suivi de dames en 2 5
laure dj mehdi fou proche des 5 et sur
dame en d1 fouet peas cac et prend et il
dit que cette finale deux tours et bien
pour les normes 1 pour les pour les
mains pendant qu'il y est que c'est un
tout petit avantage
ah non là il a changé d'avis la laïque
c'est totalement nul
c'était une fête nous bailly sénégal
notamment égal je sais même pas rien
c'est logique
donc la tourbe et 6 mai du coup la ligne
noire peuvent pas tout il peut peut-être
comme ça t il y aura des tours ok ok ça
va trop vite là je peux plus je plains
pas je fais plus rien dit
en tout cas sa garde est toujours mieux
voilà donc la prendre le pion aux 6
après le stopper le stopper ce pion à ça
devrait être assez assez simple mais bon
là de façon tout va se jouer autant
c'est c'est vraiment une question de
temps donc tout peut arriver
très donc la chope non c'est marrant
alsace et encore de gagner de gagner
autant
chacune d'entre elles c'est drôle et
bonjour la faune veille charlie a à
proposer une heure à l'autre a dit
l'aînée hockey enfin
ok donc c'est quasiment la même qu'avant
sauf que ah bah oui il sait la même
qu'avant exactement elles ont répété les
goûts donc la foux prend rêve de ses
volumes encore mais sauf lors la partie
présente les faits d'armes comme les 5
et c'est à partir donc là il vaut mieux
faire faut prendre f2 oui et leur fait
cette fois c'est bien dans ses pensées
ses coûts
donc ça a l'air pas mal pour frôler nord
ça ya peut-être des trucs du genre des
cinq qui ont envie de faire mon dessin
de carrière tout 1 tour 8
ouais donc là du coup c'est pas possible
peut-être faire c'est simple pour vous
ferez la diagonale du fou
donc faut quand même qu'un golf parce
que s'il ya wen donc là parce que tout
même si simple que ça crie ça peut ça
pète mans et surprise vint le moment on
a réussi à vous et à la diagonale du fou
est bien pire des choses c'est qu'il ya
des trucs qui peuvent et qui peut
arriver là dessus du genre cette même
dame g62 ça peut marcher
essayez de faire cavalier toi on peut tu
en d1
elle a fait c'est quoi la paix
donc sur salat c'est la question que le
faire au pied dame justice est ce que ce
que je disais ouais mais du coup la dame
appelée simplement bouger bojan relève
de l' on n'y a plus qu'à ériger 4 parce
que du coup leur auto points 8
peut-être que par l'ordi didams et
s'être mis dans cette dame aime ça te
parle anderson mais ça c'est ça un peu
bizarre
donc j'imagine la but était aussi de
faire qu'avec 3 est aussi dû garder la
pression entre l'occupant de 5 et à wil
intéressés que damas cette dame est
venue d'un enfant et deux roues avant
via calais g4 et sagan notre ouais c'est
pour ça que leur dit irina mais bien ce
coup mais où est la mauvaise à l a fait
nabli si c'est après tout c'est ce qui
est un peu bizarre pourquoi forcer 6
je sais pas je vois pas trop à un tarif
posséder sa maman
ok donc la dame c'est saddam hussein sur
le coup pour défendre les deux puis en
même temps et ouais c'est vraiment le
seul ou pas elle a gaffé là pas besoin
ok donc là elle parle bien non c'est
demain je pourrais la très dommage que
celà du coup le super bowl mais les
noirs sont bienvenus
non peut-être essayé de pousser hcg 50
ça peut se tendent et
sinon je sais pas je n'arrive pas
trouverait donc elle a fait acheter le
simple puisque à part ça je voyais pas
trop un moyen de faire des progrès avec
les noirs on voit pas mais non elle a
poussé à quatre ça nous donne un bon
moyen de ballons de poser enfin
d'attaqué cette faiblesse tellement peu
moins peur d'un mauvais quatre cadets 4
c'est un peu embêtant
en effet donc l'échangé d'un mâle
gagnant pions mais les noirs les blancs
vont regagner en furent là
donc là l'ordi marrante poussée de il
aime bien pour attaquer comme sa cavale
il a et caves et g3 pour l a fait non
mais c'est faux elle va faire ok mais
dures joutes ça passe super bien joué
elle a trouvé les coûts de l'ordi donc
là elle et les femmes
elle est pas mal et pas mais c'est
difficile de gagner ça me fait aimer
faut toujours avec deux mandats
pendant un an elle à 48 42 secondes là
les noirs sont pas mal vu jeudi deux ans
d'attenté je suis justement celle d'un
gros avantage en fait à meilhan la la
c'est là c'est assez gênant c'est mignon
pour la chinoise
donc être gagné donc cinq ennemis a trop
et demi et il reste un peu moins de 30
minutes pour les trois plus de et après
ça sera déjà l'heure du bullet
attend il s'est passé quoi là
je passais bizarre cette structure
d'accueil on est un peu bizarre je pas
sa part le poids énorme
après péter kauzer théorique mais ça me
sert à ça m'allait en plus en plus
j'espère d'abord d'avoir un pion comme
ça chante je suis pas l'équipement
doublé sa perte
même en vidant la part de flou de foin
ok f5 c'est logique pour ouvrir la
couvrir de fou donc là le cul mandat 6
donc j'imagine qu'il n'est pas trop trop
prenable parce que tour dames 30 au
point y aura peut-être français trop
suivi de f1 4
ok
donc là c'est un tracé facile de
défendre sa cause et de faire des trucs
du genre d'amener cette fois la dame
oui mesdames c'est celle de la femme
c'est sûr qu'elle éprouve aussi son
propre jeu de rencontres du cumin et
après il y aura d'un enfant d'un point
de 6 du coup dans le dessert bien ou
alors bon tour suite à prononcer que
quand même et après le clou
doc et réfléchi
rip suis longtemps elle a pas envie de
perdre ce qui manque mondiale vraiment
pas envie
ah oui car c'est bizarre ce super
bizarre c'est à cette décision surtout
sodam condé 6 l et enfin j'imagine elle
veut faire d'un g5 mais bon ça lui sert
pas à grand chose
elle perd quand même beaucoup de choses
et en plus au tamis g5 un peu juste
défendre la kf3 à ces bâtiments
donc la f3 sa maman malpaso sur dame
française soit pas mince écart est
vraiment f3 et du coup sûr j'ai 3 il y
aura des vraiment des gros se place donc
il vaut mieux prendre enfin nîmes au mur
empêcher ça et ferrer 3 ça sert pas à
grand-chose de canicule
ok donc là réfléchit encore
donc bon elle n'a pas fait f3 sur la
baie animé quelle phase iii pour
empêcher la procédure on l'a fait roi en
sa jeunesse arrive pas trop les prime
parce que il y aura quand même eu la
peau c'est être un important donc et en
plus là c'est pas trop possible de
prendre le plan c si c'est lui qui aura
toujours retour s'est vite et maintenant
le pub le cabaye et ses trois secondes à
la mbella faire du combat crew avec les
blancs gbadi donc ok disons ils font
partie en fait du coup c'est quoi le
fort moi ça se passe comment et si je
veux seulement une partie en contre ou
alors c'est les laisse m
enfin c'est une partie akinori partent
avec les blancs à éclairer les banques
ça se passe comment la fée du coup
j'avoue que je ne suis pas trop le grand
chef pour doc est donc à la poule c est
l a poussé à monde
il valait mieux faire des trucs du genre
tour des huit pour chasser la dame et
espérer que la dame prendrait en c6 et
après faire tour ses 8 n'est gagné le
cavalier ces 3 mai mais bon voilà l apf
3 donc c'est vraiment trop agressif le
bon sens parce que là elle a par trop
attaque
ouais elle a pas trop trop d'attaqués
d'amaury du 25 + 10 6 points double ok
il ya du bliss n'est pas couché pas
beach c'est pareil c'est pas lisse c'est
bizarre puis il à hilla au boycott oncle
bissau bon ok les gars ça marche
oulalala casella si ça va faire mal
ça fait super mal et y reste
pis de 2 2 quand j'ai regardé donc 22
minutes signés reste avant le passage au
pull est à quelques faits il invité que
pour moi chez eux ça marche
ok
donc les blancs gagné c'était assez
prévisible donc la lachinoise l a6 et
demi compte trois et demi c'est un déjà
en gros score mouais c'est bizarre ok ou
la a4 non mais c'est quoi ça non mais
c'est une blague ça non mais le glow le
bon mot c est un nom non mais ça se
trouve c'est après la fin de ma vie que
je vois à 4 beaucoup créatrice
mais bon salaire de sa ferme des deux
scènes d'aléas pour elle ça m'a vraiment
choquée ce coup ok donc dame g4 la seule
à vraiment pas mal adapté 4 ok donc donc
quel point ces trois ans que faire là
dessus tête on peut dès qu'on peut
reprendre en b 4 ou alors cette moyenne
en faire des trucs en jeu ça n'a pas de
sens non choquer sur dame g4 qu'elle ait
procès trois peut-être juste prendre b4
imagine
ouais parce le prendre je sais le
problème c'est qu'il y aura tour à tour
et fuite et après le cavaly il sera plus
pour la bo parce que si on fait ou si
vous fait fou d2 le lou cavaillé
repartir donc ok donc après des singles
à aulas on est bien obligé de prendre et
après faudra défendre ce qui amène donc
tant qu'on va faire foulée 3 vous faut
des deux par exemple des trucs du genre
vous détroit a peut-être fait pour
garder le fou pour le mettre en marche s
disons fou des trois cas et prend
peut-être on peut reprendre vers droit
de ea préfère faire fois çi ce but que
le fou se rend à en attaque fort avec la
tour ok fois chez le direct c'est de la
routine c'est top mais c'est le jeu dans
ce sens n'ont cessé droite droite au but
mais moi perso j'aurais bien frappe a
écoulé 3 quand même sacha ce cabaye en
plus à forcer à changer après tard fois
ci je pense que ça aurait perdu le plus
probable parce que la voix tu vois il
est pas obligé de prendre ces 3 elle
peut faire flouer 6 et continuer à son
petit développement qui va faire ça
après facebook
donc la food et 3 rebonds
al messai du coup ça transposant peut il
n'y a pas trop de différence
ouais du coup c'est quasiment la même
fête donc fou des trois cas y procès
trois la reprise faut prendre et après
on met laurent eu deux images et sur fou
prend à rabat sur coup franc on prend et
fit donc là haut il ya peut-être des
fous prend les quatre suivi deux tours
des mains ou alors ouais lantourne pour
nonce à la salle dont vous prend 1,15
soir était le coup mais bon la faf est
donc là elle laisse les noirs le way la
chanteuse de tango rock
wen en place et ça c'est top pour les
bons temps que temps que charline ne
seront pas des tours tours g8 celui de
fous des saints ont détruit du genre ça
devrait aller non là non le look ou
arrive mais c'est bof c'est pas un
problème parce que la dame peut revenir
à la maison
défendre loc
par exemple la mer trois navires
français bien ça en plus a attaquent le
plan b 7
vous aurez donc ces six ok je vois
aujourd'hui plutôt fou des 5
donc là elle a fait à 5 donc je veux
pousser clairement poussé loin sa force
les blondes s'appliquer c'est tuer et
piller la les changes ou alors on peut
faire des trucs du genre damas damas
cinq ou six ou alors simplement bouger à
la dame mais ça je pense que c'est un
peu plus dangereux mais non d'un machin
de salaires des bien dommage sans
salaire
donc ce qu'il faut calculer c'est ça en
fait faut prendre j'ai deux tours tours
g8
il faut voir si un moyen de défendre
donc ça si vous vous prononcez cinq que
se passe-t-il à j'imagine d'un monde
dames g4 j'imagine dame g4 et il y aura
des petits problèmes mais on a des gros
problèmes en fait de sacrés problèmes
parce que les blancs doivent défendre le
fou et en plus il ya la menace de faux
en g2 ça va super bien vu ce souffle
c'est fou ces cinq est là maintenant il
ya toujours g4 qui arrive qui attaquent
la dame et aussi le fond du court et si
la dame repart après tour de gassies là
dedans en f3 il y aura dix idées là
allez donc la lega fait c'est dommage je
pourrais qu'elle n'ait pas vu ce coup
c'est un peu surprenant d'ailleurs parce
que c'était assez assez simples amis
harvick a vécu une seconde pour valider
ça va être compliqué ça va être
compliqué
bon elle remonte au temps
dames g4 salaires top parce que sa
menace de prendre en hd après matt
battant angers 2 calebasse la toro et
après mali donc hop est bien joué j'ai
bien aimé sont fous ces cinq c'était
vraiment bienvenue donc cet ennemi à
trois et demie prenant le match n'a pas
prétendu
et il reste un peu moins de 15 minutes
et après ça sera déjà l'heure du bullet
donc est d'ailleurs juste pour info
après ce match là il y aura encore en
autres matches il va reprendre
en fait ça ça commence si je dis pas de
bêtises
monsieur je crois que ça commença à 17
heures heure française
je crois le prochain match ça sera entre
deux joueuses des nouvelles joueuses
donc là aujourd'hui un spécialement il y
à il ya deux rondes en fin de match
aujourd'hui
d'habitude ya seulement en match par
jour mais là il y en a deux donc là je
pense que je suis juste faire un super
l'un stream de tête 7 7 heures pendant
qu'à donc ça lui coule vraiment pas
besoin d'arrêter le stream prévu que vu
que ça s'enchaîne et surtout si elles
font les départage si la trouve les
parties sochaux je crois même maison
même peut-être même pas fini ce match
avant le prochain
donc ok alors que se passe-t-il donc bon
c'est cette ouverture
personnellement j'aime pas trop la jouer
avec les blancs j'aime pas trop c'est ce
genre de position mais après il y en a
des qui ya mis un encore passé justin
c'est juste une préférence personnelle
on l'a faut peut-être sortir la dame de
coeur des truc c'est de défendre ce que
l'on perd des dames c'est en tête pour
attaquer la poussée b4 aussi et
peut-être
ouais donc dame séance un stand
peut-être et après faire faire foule 3
aussi une fois qu'il aura juan h7 faux
et 3 pour attaquer ceux qui m'ont 5
ok alors là si on prend l'occurrence 7 5
je pense qu'il y aura alliaura fou prend
f3 qui doublera la structure de pions
sur tout ça rendra le rock super faible
banques
il faut en effet éviter de faire ça mon
plat qu'avec des deux c'est plus normal
s'attaque le foot ça menace peut-être de
le prendre ou qu'il y aura peut-être
faut prendre ces cinq maintenant donc la
gâteau en france et 5 maintenant le fou
est vraiment attaqué il ya aussi la
relaxe de k&b this way ça allait avoir
un lien pour les blancs je pense que ça
ne va pas possible en fait de défendre
le fou et la menace qu'elle a et b 6
parce que c'est elle fait un coup du
genre ça je pense qu'il y aura même f3
veut gagner qui veut gagner fou et si
elle fait d'un médecin qui accable des
six donc c'est vraiment possible de
défendre se fout là pas de défendre ce
fou empêchant la menace cavaliers
cabinet sis s'agit pas possible donc là
je pense segura mentales font les blancs
démarrent donc là si elle garde cette
partie 8,8 et demi à rafah trois ennemis
ça aide vraiment vraiment difficile
pendant dix ans
donc là il ya quand même une hausse
quand même faire x 6 mais c'est pas si
grave comme ça je pense moi qu'elle s'en
fiche sur fou htc l'a dû voir quelque
chose peut-être juste prendre au f5 et
après je pense que ça la dérange pas de
perdre 7 7 tours en q3 parce que elle a
quand même déjà une école enfin donc a
été plus donc oui elle aura fait ça
prend 25 jours à une superposition
donc c'est un bon choix est là je pense
qu'elle peut même me sacrifier la tour
devrait qu'être leur sacrifier la
qualité pendant le sis a prévenu elle
avec sa dame angers 5
elle sera totalement gagnante parce que
le pion g6 sera attaquée est le pion h5
mais elle n'aura pas fait ça et l'a fait
à ok ok mais on l'a pas vu ça en fait
elle aurait pu faire elle aurait pu
prendre six à prévenir angers 5 mai elle
a choisi de venir la place donc l
attaque directe le kg hommage samedi
oui ce qui est très bien aussi c'est
super bien aussi en fait est ce qu'il
veut et peut toujours le faire
d'ailleurs s'est passé pas trop tard
ouais mais elle peut faire ça et après
d'âpres en achetant excitables au hockey
donc là un bon j'imagine que c'était
juste prendra que la dame passe pas ce
prêt va se prendre la tête
très donc là c'est je suis c'est archi
marché sont donc ok donc à échanger les
dom
j'aurais pas venu c'était nécessaire
s'il n'y avait pas trop manqué y avait
dans mon coin m2 mais là c'était pas une
grosse wallace a défendu mais oui c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que vaut mieux ne
pas trop se prendre la tête et c'est de
faire les choses simplement
là on peut peut-être juste pousser les
pions
wep ou ch tis a l'air vraiment top
dont il reste d'ailleurs vie mousse donc
je pense que oui il y aura deux de
partir en glisse et après ça sera
l'heure du bullet depuis ça sera
vraiment que j'adore le blé j'adore
regarder le bullet ya tellement de gafsa
c'est drôle ou et aussi tout peut
arriver
si la trouvaille charlie sera eu mon
stress de bull est bonne après midi
radar donc là c'est très calme dans le
chat je vois que vous n'êtes pas très
bavarde aujourd'hui mais c'est pas grave
mais mimoun le ghana donc là c'est
totalement gagnant yahia fou j'ai vite
elle a peut-être tour cette photo qui va
prendre en bessette salaire au ballon
même prendre on peut même prendre la
whey un peu juste prononcé quatre
proprement raciste ou les fientes angle
csa incroyable tous les plans mais ce
juge est de pousser les pions à ces
lignes ouais elle peut aussi pousser ses
pions
temps
donc elle a gagné la gagne donc là je
pense qu'il reste haïti reste en plus
loin un peu plus de six minutes donc là
je pense plié il y aura deux parties
encore qu'ils vont jouer deux parties et
voilà donc leur système de londres ça
pour moi qu'on voit cette ouverture
c'est quoi donc voir on va du nouveau
elles ont changé un peu
d'après deux femmes se sentent peut-être
que là c'est vrai caïd de ces quatre là
je pense que la dame elle peut repartir
mais bon c'est vrai que c'est un peu
risqué donc là préféré ne pas le faire
bon là c'est vraiment typique le jeu des
blancs pendant tour c'est un an par
exemple ça aussi savoir mettre la table
à peut-être cavale il a aussi ses biens
budam le 2 c'est normal bam c2c à perdre
je pense qu'il aurait calé b4 donc
l'annoncé d'un bond de sa nécessaire
pèse sur sa c5
mais sur quel essai 5 du coup il y
aurait faut aussi à 8 ça est d'arriver
noir en pâte
donc vous savez bien qu'elle n'a pas
fait wen dans tous les cas ils allaient
faire fouillis du coup fait recaler
c'est ça que ça s'arrête de réajustement
a chassé le fou 1,8
tom ces deux voies non j'ai pas ce jazz
est fait c'est bizarre permettre la dame
soit même colin de la tour même si ça
crée des menaces là bas je pense que
vous nous invitez à ben plus sur d'armes
ces deux têtes recueillies avec un pib
quatre aussi des trucs du genre ouais sa
valeur de marché donc ouais d'un tir
d'obus
dans ces 2
donc là peut être échangée d'avancé 5
mais je suis pas sûr que les changes se
soit bien on vaut mieux garder d'un
jugement en fait ce genre de pollution
c'est pas si simple à jouer
peut-être qu'elle veut mettre le gagnant
6 4 mètres l'autre camp ces cinq
peut-être
[Musique]
donc là le cailly échassiers on s'écarte
c'est logique vingtaine rentrée en d6
aussi choqué en france et 4 on peut
reprendre avec le fou pour occuper à
diagonale et créer des choses comme ça
donc avec la dame c'est bien aussi
la dame peut peut-être rentrer ensuite
aussi maintenant ouais ça c'est sûr sur
bénéfices bien sûr on prend 8 donc elle
avoue j'espère voir dames de huit mois
ont du coup le fouet à l'attaqué donc
elle aura un choix de soir revenir à la
maison soit échangé les dames en 1 8
donc disons prendre en 8 après faire des
trucs du genre du genre qu'a laissé cinq
peut-être pour attaquer les deux pions
ça a l'air de gagner en pions en fait
d'un v8 d'un point 8 faut en ont égalisé
5 t on peut prendre là il a préféré dans
une baie vitrée après s'est fait recaler
des six ça peut se tenter
bienvenue bienvenus après je ne sais pas
si ça c'est vraiment pas s'il a gagné
même avec le plus en plus je pense pas
que c'est un c'est que ces patients
lyon accueille cagliari en c4 et je
pense que s'il allait briser change ça
risque vraiment d'être mieux ou alors
peut-être pas mal pour les noirs pendant
sa retraite plutôt mieux je pense à moi
des trois bons choix
o le temps vient de s'écouler donc je
pensais qu'elle allait réussir à faire
de deux parties non mais non donc là vu
qu'elles n'ont pas recommencé une
nouvelle partie cela c'est déjà fini
et ça sera l'heure du bullet et le
bullet cette salle est super cool à
avoir donc là ça a l'air d'être une
finale archi nul ça a l'air d'être
vraiment nul donc comme lala les deux
côtés peuvent en parcours tenté des
choses mais ouais mais pour le moment
c'est pas simple petit prendre en 7 5
après cette passe et le cavalier ok donc
j'ai 3 mai dans une case dans des cinq
ou six qu'on peut utiliser
ok
aubin
ouais ok ça c'est totalement nul surtout
celle des charges les pions
ah parce qu'il verra sept secondes c'est
pour ça ouais c'est pour ça qu'elle a
essayé de vraiment de chercher lannion
donc là c'est fini
elles ont repris une partie elles ont
recommencé une partie mais c'est fini là
ça sera l'ère du but est donc là il y
aura encore une pause y auront encore
une pause et après ça sera ça sera
l'heure du mil est donc bon en attendant
aussi je vais faire ma petite pause et
je me retrouve dans cinq minutes quand
les partis eux reprendront donc pas tout
de suite
ok comme je suis de retour et les
parties moment repris donc
voilà donc là c'était une vingtaine
d'ouverture assez bizarre avec avec la
sso vos premiers c'est un c'est assez
surprenant mais bon là c'est là c'est
l'heure du bullet donc il y aura
beaucoup plus de gars que ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a vu en avant
ok donc là je pense que c'est déjà un
gros avantage pour les noirs je trouve
que c'est une belle position que ce
qu'elle a en cas de qu'avait lieu de le
fou aura juste travailler en trois sets
pas un souci elle a aidé un chassables
aussi à la paire de fous aussi des
poussées en d5 peut-être
bon c'est vrai que le cahier peut causer
de créer des menaces mais quand il
arriva en déça comprendra simplement
ou alors on peut juste faire autre chose
peut-être comprendre ajouté à prendre
pendant un deux et sur tourbe et de il y
avait foule et 4 donc bien sûr peu
qu'elle a fait à quatre maisons
accueillent des simples s'est jamais
posée on n'y pense même pas
ok donc là le fouet le fou que je vais
partir mon oeil si en échange de
toujours ça serait gagnant pour les
noirs quasiment pas ça serait gagnée en
fait s'ils prennent là parce qu'il y
aurait des trucs horribles donc la
touques mambé trois places et gagne
parce que le foot devant la tour donc
wait chabbiha seront cinq à neuf est là
donc c'est à ce que le budget c'est
vraiment sa force
ça serait cool ça serait marrant qu'elle
arrive à se remonter
donc là c'est un non sens type de deux
systèmes de monde pour ce qu'elle a fait
mais là ça ressemble plus du tout un
système de nombreux que les pions cd
sont tous partis
la tête voilà puis on l'a peut-être
ouais on avait déjà vu cette heure je me
rappelle on avait déjà vu cette cette
position avant
donc là il peut y avoir aussi à moi même
mon ca du blitz nous vous ça va super
vite mais rend peu plus tôt ici aulas je
pensais à cavaliers pourront en fait
d'abord tout reprend ses entours pan et
après cavaliers prend 2,3 vu que le fou
des trois ne serait plus défendu vu
qu'un tour seraient anciens on peut
prendre après bon quoi voilà donc ça
c'était juste fort était cool mais elle
l'a pas fait donc voilà ce qui se passe
ok poussée de lv échangés après rentrée
avec la tour sur la sur l'a20 j'ai ça
c'est logique
donc là et sion il aura peut-être par la
tourelle peut pas rentrer sur la sixième
c'est ça le prévenant que la tour ces
objets de peut-être venir défense ils
gagnent ancien homme de parole et bon ça
c'est là beaucoup doux
de quoi ont été joués depuis donc ça a
l'air trés écoles savez
bondy nord ont réussi à choper le bio
c'est cool pour al saqqaf faire des
trucs du genre ça aussi plus tard mais
n'ont pu maintenant bien sûr comme
maintenant c'est la question est il faut
échanger ou quoi lord il aime bien ce
coup kelly 17 en plus le roi il veut pas
rentrer donc ouais ça c'est bien c'est
bien pour entrer en d4
je pense que ça devrait être une belle
position pour les north à wayne en fait
non c'est le snu il ya trop pions qu'il
se sent différent j'essaye juste niveau
seulement parce que les deux côtés
pousse surtout grâce au temps où tout
peut encore arriver
ouais donc là et joue elle joue elle
tourne mais là c'est nul ça ça ne peut
pas être autre chose que nullement qu'il
ait une grosse gaffe
oh c'est bien vu sa hausse et gagne 1
pour les bancs maintenant assez fou
c'est fou du coup elle a gagné bref si
c'est après écoute ça c'est vous c'est
fini bien vous ai bien joué
d'ailleurs sont alloués l'abri mais elle
a dû 1700 et en budget et ça veut dire
qu'elle va vraiment causé des
préversions de vera sorcières est
probable a réussi à gagner le match
grâce à toi parce que et là il explose
adversaires en bullet la l'indiana
elle en train de vraiment elle joue bien
c'est pas mal
donc là le cabinet va sûrement se fâcher
lang fr est là ok donc là ça ouais donc
elle a fait h cartes bancaires pousser
les pions prison ces six quais les ponts
foudre en bessin au mont-houy y aura
peut-être des trucs du genre français 3
ou alors non je store jeu se développer
donc tête français 3 suivi d'un masque
en fait ouais parce que sur fond noir
faut préciser s'il y avait d'un français
3 et la paix en reprenait faux mail à
pamiers est la part des français 3 il
n'a pas voulu donner soif ou qui était
un cadeau c'est pour ça mais je pense
qu'elle aurait dû le faire
donc la b5 football donc là le calibre
entrer ici on peut l'empêcher par da luz
part d'amd 3 ou alors on peut l'ignorer
mais faire entrer toujours acheter mais
je pense si vous mélangez tout ça peut
être assez problématique ce qu on peut
aussi faire un caïd de oued et 5 c'est
malin on peut reprendre avec la dame à
prévenir en b2
je crois que la dame à les enfermer
avait obligé de sacs et l'ademe ok donc
d'armes contre mais il ya un bail
d'opium au monde livre pour les blancs
du coup je pense que ça devrait être une
belle cohésion pour les bons surtout
c'est l'arrêt pas rentrer là on a le roi
des fonds quand même mais bon ça devrait
être assez parce que les pions sont très
forts tels qu'on peut faire d'un chipset
par exemple et c'est de rentrer à peut
faire c'est 5 6 10 6 pouces et
ouais ça s'est fini c'est fini c'est
fini c'est fini
il suffit juste de pousser les pions et
sow sera gagnant
il faut pas qu'elle fait qu'il donne sa
dame
le temps des noirs est aussi très
mauvais ouais la promotion c'est fini ok
donc lâché nous a réussi à regagner donc
10 1 6 donc bye chali à l'est s'est
rompue de martigues et copains mais je
pense que ça sera pas assez pour gagner
match donc là c'est un courant système
de londres on a l'habitude de voir ça
mais sans une ligne différente j'ai
l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas encore
joué ça ils ont changé un peu
si sa vitesse devient donc si on prend
en b 6
ouais ça au vrai je suis donc ce n'était
pas forcément au mans pour pour les
blancs donc là le pion cinq attaques il
ya aussi des petites menaces sur le
curage tête surtout si huit auquel a pas
bien sans la faillite
[Musique]
bah je parle trop peu juste pour louis
je vois pas trop de façon de continuer
avec bon nombre ou la la il ya peut-être
qu'elle est prête à 8 euros pour les
trois ans après il faut à tout prix
après faut prendre quatre
car en france on préfère faut descendre
vers wen ont fait dix ans que ça passe
en juste prendre ensuite vu que là
surtout reprend il y avait deux premiers
singles c'est pour ça qu'il est relou
donc là les normes en plus peut-être que
ça va compter mes lordi dame vient pas
il aime bien il aime bien et noir ont
fait ça va pour pour l'être une vie
donc là peut être que les noirs peuvent
essayer de pousser les pions aussi hors
aussi faire un cahier dé 6,7 au ciel en
échange de cavalli ça serait en ça
serait bien pour les noirs sur donc
notre cas mais il n'est pas très actif
ces cas veillez à ces foires donc
il ya peut-être la perf est tuant ses
huit pour bell tour de 8 pour sa tournée
ça dansait vite pour 2,8
du coup elle a évité mais elle se prend
qu'elle est de 5 donc elle à l'indienne
dragani l'on dirait tout retour c'est
cette c'est fini bon en soit si elle est
ici au mans ça n'a pas lu dommage pour
elle
sur ces 7 c'était assez défini
donc il y aura ce cap seconde celle
arrive à gagner ça mais bon c'est chaud
je pense que c'est même appareil voici
ces faits comme gagnable je pense mais
n'ont pas vraiment plu de la tuque rouge
c'est peut-être les noirs tout de même
la montage où là c'est un gros avantage
aux normes
ouhlala ouais du coup c'est la chêneraie
ce qu'il va encore gagner
ouais je pense que j'ai pas réussi à
regagner sans même avec heures six
mandats la pan de sa sera ainsi elle a
abandonné alors il reste plus que moi il
reste mans 8 8 minutes et demie et après
ça sera la fin du match ça va être très
difficile de remonter pour pour vérifier
qu'elle ne pense qu'il y aura même pas
de départager lors
voilà donc faut juste revenir avec le
fou moi c'est bizarre il apparaît ok
c'est bizarre d'avoir de s'être
volontiers un film dans les murs revenir
à kiev où je pense qu'elle au wind corp
donc ok il changer les dames mais
surtout prend la 4 e je sais pas je
pense que non c'est pas une gaffe
publique et après on prend 6,6 après le
prendre ok ça c'est bien vu c'est mieux
ouais ça c'est bien
ainsi donc là ils menacent de prendre
ouais ok là mais non elle apprend à
acheter
ça c'est pas matt damon mais il a tout
fait pour entrer ou si elle veut faire
des petites menaces en d2 en d1
pas si simple
aussi vous dire que surtout pour celles
qui auraient eu fou il faut des quatre
qu'un tacle le pion f
c'est très tendu de ça
bon bah je pense que le meilleur ou qui
ont des blancs 7 prendre ici après
prendre le enfin après les cli noir
prennent ici faire voix à royan et
essayer de prendre le point 4 je pense
que ce plan va tomber parce que sur e3
il y aura sûrement tout regard très
après on prend le le faut je pense que
ce fut en 3 bat va tomber
mais demain ça a l'air d'être en
avantage pour les blancs bien sûr après
gagner ça c'est une autre histoire
surtout avec anglet
pas si simple voilà salaire de haut avec
ses cartes c'est bien ça elle est donc
elle a encore gagné
elle encore gagné et samson est lourd et
je crois qu'elle a gagné 200 points en
vu l'autisme depuis depuis le début du
match
ouais c'est fou ça ok donc elles ont
refait le système de londres encore une
fois
oui
donc cette fois la ligne en plus
différente parce que alors en général va
et charlie pousser toujours c4 mais
cette fois elle a changé de planque donc
la jouer un peu plus le système de l'ong
classique mais je pense que vaille chez
les [ __ ] 12 de 4 da prêteront à vue
parce que la première partira toujours
commencer par l'écossaise donc peut-être
que ça lui convient pas trop ce genre de
de police et ont permis à va donc à tour
h 3à et de venir manger 3 ok intéressant
g4 hockey pas mal pas mal c'est ce que
j'aime bien
mais à tête de calais qui pourrait enfin
h théâtre après qui peut venir angers 6
aussi claire grand roque s'appelle bien
pour ramener la tour en géant mais bon
si on fait grand que la position faute
sera très dangereuse parce qu'il y aura
beaucoup d' attaque sur la lnah donc là
je pense que là lé nord ils ont réussi à
trouver une belle attaque c'est pas si
simple parce qu'elle a vraiment tourné
et à tourner tourner tourner et n'a pas
trop su comment attaquer les rois du
coup elle a laissé en plus de chances au
nord donc laquelle est fort bien suivie
de quatre salaires de salaire de
peut-être pas mal donc
peut-être qu'il ya des petites menaces
sont avec vous prend ainsi c'est pour ça
qu'à elle a défendu avec cavaliers avec
euros ht est à f3 voyage froid c'est
cool donc là je pense que ces gros
avantage pour les blancs elle a réussi à
ouvrir les lignes au regard des
diagonales
2k vaio cette pièce parker pas faire
mieux l'histoire
ça serait un peu dommage pour elle
c'est fini
mais non et la gaffe et ses poses qui
vient d'arriver là mais c'est fou et la
peine qu'a fait incroyable très bien
croyable ou là lol non mais à bord la
coalition qu'est la veille après après
une loupe et le gain comme ça ça donne
vraiment un
je pense que la barre est à bouloire été
des échecs après ça rend plus à
vendenheim
aulas c'est moche moi j'étais moche et
elle entend maintenant il fera cage là
je crois donc là et loi mais elle était
totalement gagnante mais bon deux mois
je pourrai
donc ajoute pour staline à chaque fois
on a déjà vu ça pas mal de poids et
d'ailleurs il reste plus beaucoup de
temps il reste à peine dix minutes aux
bouteilles donc ça ça beaucoup de chance
d'être la dernière partie est donc oui
ça serait la fin du match parce que je
suis enfant et clairement pas de
départage pas ce que sont vraiment pas
proches mis au point donc ouais donc ça
ça risque d'être la partie finale et
c'est déjà un gros avantage pour les
blancs je pense qu'elles ajustent
craquer csl demain le forez mais c'est
dommage pour elle
donc ok donc là on peut peut-être
pendant en dc ou alors faire bouger ça
que ça a l'air bien sûr aux termes de
cette loi on peut en plus juste prendre
des six affaires vous l'a peut-être way
ok donc sur d'infopresse invaincus tout
en 71 6 4 2 6 mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils avaient des idées fraîches près
de rodez vite ceci a donc le temps vient
de s'écouler
c'est la fin ça la fin du match donc ça
ne sera la dernière partie
officiellement donc voilà donc ça je
pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de chance
pour veiller xavi je pense que ça n'est
pas assez égales cette nuit je mens bon
qu'elle se prend pas des trucs sur soi
sur l'année le ca s'était rangée
donc si tours sète j'imagine que leurs
atours f7 qui comptera un peu la menace
olalala ces modes psam à 100 donc
lighting reagan la dernière partie bravo
elle est là elle a bien joué ce match
elle a vraiment bien joué donc l'iphone
qui refont une partie peut juste pour le
plaisir
non mais c'est la face à la famille -
ils vont arrêter cette partie oui donc
bon c'est la fin du match donc donc
lighting guy a gagné 14 6 donc c'est
vraiment gros score pour elles et eux
en fait moi je vais revenir dans environ
40 minutes parce qu'il y aura un nouveau
match en fait donc là je vais vous juste
nous mettre les appariements
donc voici ce qui se passe donc là c'est
tellement chantre lighting dit eva joly
est là dans 40 minutes on va repasser au
match entre deux ukrainiennes qui seront
à même aux ebooks et il ya un os mac
donc voilà donc vous pouvez là je vais
arrêter le stream mais je vais reprendre
dans 40 minutes donc vous pourrez
assister à beaucoup plus de spectacle à
ce moment là donc voilà donc c'était un
très bon match de la part de linking j
donc je vous dis à très bientôt a très
vite et je serai de retour comme comme
dit dans 40